Moe, moe, boo!
Okae, no sir!
Ojo, sir!
Hello everybody!
Welcome back!
Last, last episode of the wolf.
Oh my gosh.
This, all of our answers will be...
No, all of our questions!
Wait.
All of our questions will be answered!
I wanted to look at the book of fables right quick.
Oh wait, I always miss at least two things.
I guess it depends on if I go one direction or the other
direction, but interesting acting deputy snow white, all of
the information, the silver bullets, the crooked layer,
that's where we're at right now.
Bluebeard's money.
One might think that Bluebeard donates funds to the Fable
Tower.
government for nefarious purposes seeking special favors or
to have a louder voice in government proceedings but what he
really wants is stability and strength because as far as
bluebeard is concerned fabletown exists to insulate him from
the mundi world as much as his money can be a sword it can
also be a shield yeah i wonder if there are people that i
mean obviously like they use the glamours to hide themselves
from the Mondays so that they can kind of coexist.
Well, it's not really co-I mean, it's co-existing, but the
Mondays don't really know anything about it, it seems.
But also, I wonder if there's a group of people that are
like, no, we deserve, we should live as ourselves with no
glamours and this and that.
I wonder.
really come up or anything probably i imagine humans are a
little mean maybe fabletown is a community located on
bullfinch street in manhattan's upper west side to regular
people are mondays it appears to be an ordinary new york
neighborhood but it is really the home of fables for many
worlds and within the business office of the woodlands lies
a massive cavern yeah a vast library and hundreds of magical
items of immense power all non-human fables live upside Oh,
upstate on the farm.
An extension of Fable Town.
Cool.
Shall we?
Do.
The last episode!
Let's go!
Let's just get into it.
Oh!
Cry wolf!
That don't look...
We're just gonna ignore the blood all over his hands?
I mean, your eyes and the teeth?
You're not really supposed to that are you oops oops my bad
not if i can avoid it slip of the finger it's
been so long since we saw faith but except it's only been
like i guess a couple days this is all happening within just
like less than a week basically sister lily do you even give
a about us The straights.
That's why you can't tell me anything.
It's the ribbon.
The ribbon.
That's why it was in her mouth.
That's kind of crazy.
No!
Oh, we didn't do that.
We're not burning the tree, Snow.
Hey, you're not really gonna send me to the farm, are you?
Nah.
Snow will come around.
She's just...
The crane thing hit her hard, and she doesn't really know
who her friends are right now.
Oh gosh, that was so stinking loud.
Bloody Mary.
Oh God, Bigby.
This time was no joke.
Eat as many metal shellings as you see fit, but take just
one more silver round near your heart.
And the only place I'll be visiting you...
How are we going to make it out of this alive, I wonder?
Bigby, wait.
When you get the crooked man, make sure you bring him back
alive.
He has to stand trial.
Okay.
Why don't you have a seat, Sheriff?
We have a great deal to discuss.
Yes, we do.
Oh my gosh, we don't even like...
Don't even...
We just have the recap and straight into the episode.
It's like when your favorite anime has no opening.
And you're like, oh, oh, oh, it's about to go down.
Oh, this episode?
Okay.
I mean, it is the last one.
song is so good
cry wolf episode 5 you've come a long way
you must be tired yeah I did do that
so it's the crooked man the guy that like lived in the
crooked house and this and that
oh we've been taking that out for huh please share Uh, then
your guy can put his gun away.
His guns away.
Vivian makes a very nice, very...
It's elegant.
Really, uh, Carpaccio.
It's lobster.
I'm here for one reason.
And it's not to eat your fucking food.
Oh, really?
You came...
You didn't come here for the food?
Hey!
What do you think you're doing?
yeah mr.
wolf is our guest and I have he's gonna what he's gonna I'm
going wolf don't waste the silver sit down Jersey he's gonna
I'm gonna work for the sake of transparency why don't you
tell us why you're here it would help settle everyone's
nerves I think you killed those women you know why I'm here
yeah killed those women what women faith and Lily the girl
who worked at the pudding and pie did I know I assume by
your confidence in accusing me you must have some proof of
this yes some allotment of evidence Jersey told me you did
it your servant over there told me yeah that's a fucking lie
I didn't say anything like that all I said was that this was
your town and nothing wouldn't happen without your approval
all right that's it so the girls true those women I I don't
relish telling you that the killings were perpetrated by an
employee of mine.
Looks at Georgie.
It's a very unfortunate bit of business, but I promise you,
but the matter will be dealt with internally.
I just want to settle the issue for you and to assure you
that it's over with.
Well, who did it?
An unfortunate bit of business?
You're going to tell me right now who killed her.
A crooked man will remember that.
I have complete respect for you and your job.
I hope you know that.
But I simply can't divulge that information.
the back you really shouldn't worry yourself as i said i've
got this under control he's just got no control i'm gonna
deal with it right now yeah right shut up jersey some kind
of negotiation
the man said he'd take care of it so why don't you take the
hint and get out you're pissing me already pissed off you
don't want to make it worse oh i think i do i'd love a good
reason to put eyes after what you did that's enough i was
hoping it wouldn't come to this but in the interest of
preserving our alliance alliance i don't think we have an
alliance it was georgie georgie
however like i said what does that look for georgie you got
what you wanted so just sit down now
Yeah, I killed him so what why'd you do it?
You should have just kept your nose where it fucking
belonged.
Why'd you do it?
Why kill them?
Does it matter yeah, the fact is yeah, I think it does
George here misinterpreted one of my instructions
misinterpreted Oh, things right.
So let's work something out the girls are fighting I'm
protected aren't I your protection has limits and I think
you far exceeded yours But you could murder someone in cold
blood like that.
You fucking asked me to do this.
And then attempt to blame me for it.
You will be silent while we discuss what to do with you.
This is right, bollocks, sis.
Bollocks.
You're just gonna let him do this?
Oh, yeah, you could be next.
Uh...
So what do you say, Sheriff?
Can we discuss terms?
You can have Georgie.
Consider it a gift.
Ensuring our continued cooperation.
Yeah, take this fucker take all of them I didn't fucking
start this no deals no deals it's over so get up You're all
accomplices You can't just hand me over what the fuck is
this shit?
You said you'd cover for us for minor infractions not murder
just go with him, Georgia You're gonna sink us off.
What's wrong with you people?
You're really really are just selling him out I can't give a
fuck if I'm the one who the shit do you think you fuckers
are the girls are fighting this is so can i get back to that
laughter i'm going with him you kidding me a certain line
you mentioned pleasant and i would rather you weren't here
to watch you can go join that all at the bottom of the lake
for all i give a but he's not taking me anywhere it's this
face he's making i'll roll over on the lot of you before i
let that up and what are you saying yeah what the what if i
grab the crooked man we all go down this with you let's do
it i'm running out fuck around here this could have gone so
well but you just had to complicate things oh me to speak
the truth I've never been a very good mediator why negotiate
when you can just decide oh oh bloody Mary oh oh did I miss
anything Well, look at you all fixed up.
Kind of.
Oh!
There was no quick time thing, was there?
The joysy devil.
He's still injured, too, though.
Wait!
You're done, wolf.
I thought we were on your side too though.
Or not George.
Uh, wait.
Hey!
I'd like to see it was nice to know you.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'd like to see your insides turned out.
Oops.
Friendly fire a little bit.
Oh, oh, God.
Is George here?
This way.
Oh.
Go, go, go.
No, no, you should probably like...
Go, go, go, I mean.
Like, go through the portal and catch up with them.
Or something.
Oh, everybody's just...
Into the nether.
Minecraft.
Ouch, ouch.
Cute, cute, cute, cute, cute, cute, cute.
Yeah, look at you burning that rubber!
Oh, dang, flimsy car.
I hope nobody notices the wolf man running through the
streets.
Oh.
Holy cow.
Oh!
What is my health bar?
Up!
Jump!
And jump!
It's all for a movie, folks.
We're filming a wolf.
What's that?
Wolfman in London?
No, no.
Wolfman in New York.
We'll just cast a really big old spaghetti spell on them,
you know?
Don't worry about it.
I can't look over at you guys.
I gotta pay attention.
Even though nobody's even there.
It's just me.
It's no chat to look at.
Did you jump?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
That's a big cat.
That's the right car, right?
Yeah, okay, good.
I almost landed on the wrong car.
I just landed on the bus.
Oh, wait.
That's a crooked man.
Oh, dang it.
I should have landed on the other one.
Let's, uh, reach in.
I can't tell what the timer is at the bottom though.
Come on big B.
Really glad his pants still fit when he releases the dog.
I'm gonna lose him!
Come on.
Come on, Grandpa.
It's past your bedtime.
Oh, good.
Somebody in left clothes that look exactly like mine right
there.
Hmm.
Anything in here?
You know?
The blood.
I don't know why we're examining, but...
Did I do that?
Not bad.
Georgie will be fine maybe.
I don't really care, honestly.
She kind of sucks.
Come on.
We can't stay here.
I'm not gonna listen.
Hang on.
I need a minute.
Okay.
Listen first.
Shh.
Can you stand up?
it's okay take your time slowly oh it's no fucking use no
way I'm walking out of here how did this happen Georgie how
did oh knock knock I'm the one who knocks shit I think
Georgie is done for hello big B I hope to 20 senses what do
you mean man's the one you want but of course you're too
much of an idiot to see that or maybe you just like me too
much to let me go you're coming with me yeah i'm taking you
down time i mean this guy your princess style haven't you
done enough look at him he's dying yeah why are you
protecting him you can't seriously want to protect this guy
you know what he did i'm not going anywhere it isn't his
fault what a murderer faith and lily he's the reason they're
dead look i know he made a few mistakes we all have right he
made sure they couldn't talk with those damn ribbons and
then he killed them you're wearing one yourself yeah that
bother you even a little knowing that man of course it does
so it's all my fucking fault then you fucking this guy just
let him you're gonna throw me to the fucking wolf too you
know i didn't have a goddamn choice what the fuck good I did
what I had so you can't fucking blame me for that look you
didn't have to do anything yeah you didn't have to do
anything yeah like hell I didn't look faith and the others
tried to pull a run on us and as you can imagine the crooked
man wasn't too thrilled but of course the big boss didn't
want to get his fucking hands dirty so he told me to take
care of it you think I don't know what that means either i
do what he says or i'm the one getting dealt with uh-huh so
i fucking killed him and i'd do it again oh because it's not
my fault the crooked man gave the order he told me to not my
fault just shut up man you think that'll help it didn't but
i felt good still the same old fucking moron go ahead and
arrest me then but it won't bring back lily your face that's
not the issue your friend Narissa and I'm just the sap
taking the fall for the whole thing we can arrest all of you
guys just come in here and blame me for all this shit jobs
done right everybody's trying to guilt trip me but it's kind
of crazy like what was I supposed to do what do you need you
You could have let them go!
You could have done anything else.
You could have let them go.
Yeah!
You could have freed Faith and Lily from those fucking
ribbons instead of murdering them.
You don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
If I freed them...
Yeah?
What?
What would you have me do?
Kill her.
George, you don't.
It was them or Vivian.
So you tell me, if Free and Lily meant she had to die.
What?
Why?
What do you mean?
Do you still think I had a fucking choice?
about this is the original huh the girl with the ribbon I'm
sure you've heard the story yes oh my gosh the one I've been
talking about it she used her little purple ribbon to make
more of them to keep our girls quiet to ensure absolute
discretion promised you wouldn't oh all that magic is
connected to this little thing you remove hers and the
spells broken they're all free but you know what happens to
her the same thing that happens to faith so don't you come
in here and tell me i fucked up what the hell georgie we
were supposed to look out for each other i trusted you you
can't fucking blame how could you yeah why would you say how
could you do this why would you give them the same fate i
thought you cared about them i do of course i do you have to
understand nobody was supposed to die when we built this
place it it was just a stupid idea a gimmick discretion is
our guarantee our lips are sealed This was supposed to be
our place.
We were going to be in charge for once, and nobody would try
to control us or use us.
That was the point.
Then the crooked man showed up and everything just turned to
shit.
So, do you get it now?
Why I couldn't just...
If you still think it's so fucking simple, then you do it.
Go right ahead.
Kill her then.
What are you doing?
Break the spell.
Save the fucking day.
Stop it.
I told you.
Sometimes all your options are shit.
What the fuck are you supposed to do then?
We'll find another way.
She doesn't have to die.
Maybe the witches can... Don't talk about me like I'm not
even here.
Please.
Vivian.
This is hard for you.
My life is such a fucking burden on your conscience.
Don't I get to say it's my life.
Like it was either of yours to give up in the first place.
Well, you're kind of involved.
get a choice if you're involved in this i know what i've
done wait i'm sick of everyone thinking that they can just
do what they want with my life i thought it would be
different here but it's all the fucking season i didn't mean
do you think i wanted to be this person what i did to faith
and lily to all of them oh is she gonna do it i every day i
have to look gwen and hans in the eye and pretend i don't
care i have to forget what i've done to them what i took
away from them i look at narissa and i hate myself vivian i
can't pretend anymore what are you doing vivian don't oh no
no why'd you have to do that vivian vivian yeah i'm not
gonna say I think it's fine.
I mean, damn.
Vivian, I didn't fucking mean it.
I was just...
Oh, Jesus.
Pie.
Oh, it's just such a screwed up situation all around.
Oh, fuck.
Get up.
I don't think he can.
Don't think so, Bigby.
Eww!
I think it's time we go.
I think we both know that.
I think it's time to go up to the crooked man.
The crooked man the same treatment when you find him.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, his literal insides are...
He'll get it worse.
Worry.
Georgie will remember that.
I don't think he will.
Old foundry by the river.
all right shepherd metal works he'll be there the fucking
asshole how did his insights are coming out or do you plan
to kick me around a little first rip my limbs off one by one
hurt him that's not who I am just get it over with it's not
who I am yeah sure it's not no more games all right it's not
who I am Oh, gosh.
Just make it quick.
Who was...
I know what I did.
See ya, Georgie.
You chose to let Georgie suffer.
What?
You're just gonna leave me here.
I can't kill anyone else.
I can't do it, Georgie.
I can't take another life.
Bush busted.
Fuck you!
Piece of shit!
Oh, damn.
Dang!
Oh!
I didn't actually, I don't think I saw who, like, Georgie
was based off of his fable.
I can't believe I was right about the girl with the ribbon
this whole time.
That's crazy.
Like, literally, I called it with faith.
I love that story, though.
Shepherd Metal Works.
I mean, I think it's important that we went after...
Or not...
Well, that we saw Georgie first, because...
I mean, he has kind of the small potatoes to...
To the...
The...
You know, the crooked man.
Limousine.
Anybody in here?
Oh, where are we going?
Still warm.
He's here, all right.
Yeah.
But nobody was taking responsibility.
That's the kind of frustrating part.
Like, everyone was like, I didn't have a choice.
It's not my fault.
No.
You had a choice.
You just...
Oh.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Nice.
I were a little bit...
We were a little stone cold to Georgie, though.
Dang.
That whole situation is just sad.
But dang.
Packages.
Oh, we got...
Oh, it's a symbol.
So this is where they've been sending these.
The best safety device is a careful worker.
Let's not try to be too loud, okay?
Big B.
Inner thoughts are inner thoughts.
We don't need them to know that we're here.
One door open.
Whoa.
Wait, this looks like the place in Metal Gear!
Yes?
That's my name.
Don't worry about it.
I'm big and I'm bad.
No, I'm not bad.
I'm actually a good guy.
Oh, it's the wheel.
It's the wheel.
Wait, let's see the board first.
Oh, you're stalking me.
I have an admirer.
Wait.
Us?
Oh, this is, uh...
Wait.
Isn't that Holly and her sister and stuff?
No, because that's Faith right there.
Don't remember who these two are.
Well, what?
I guess Faith?
and what was it faith and lily wanted to leave and so they
killed them the other thing i remember is the reason i was
so like um so hard on him was because remember what tj said
he was just like when i came up i heard him say stop
laughing if they killed him if they felt bad about killing
them why were they laughing you know what i mean like unless
it was like I don't know I feel like Tweedledee or
Tweedledum would be laughing and then maybe Georgie was like
stop laughing or something like that who knows I don't know
that's me I'm looking at my smolder isn't this picture no
that looks outside I was gonna say isn't that like in the
office like who took this picture these are so close What's
up?
What telephoto lens are we using, huh?
They used to fear you.
They still fear me.
Actually they don't.
Well, who knows?
They'd hide anywhere their small shivering bodies would fit.
Cinema.
Whoa.
Bleach.
I know.
And a sledgehammer.
The torture wheel.
Oh.
Nedden.
What's in here?
What have we got?
A workbench with...
What's in this?
Silver bullets?
Uh-oh.
Silver.
The big bad wolf.
Stop being creepy.
Wee!
It's about time you showed up.
I had to take care of some things first.
Little errand boy.
That's nice.
Ah, Pigby.
I see you made it here in one piece.
I do apologize, but I have some business to attend to.
I leave you in the capable hands of my associate.
Uh-huh.
Come find me when you finish, dear.
Oh.
Don't worry.
This won't take long.
Ooh.
Get out of my way now.
Don't make this worse.
Aw.
He doesn't want to play.
I don't think she's like the last person that you want to.
I'm just going to hit her.
Oh, oh, wow.
That was embarrassing.
What a man.
Stealing punches while my back is turned.
Oh, she's mad at me.
What is she disappearing into?
Like, what reflection?
It's like that's kind of her thing, right?
To go through mirrors and all that.
Oh, it's crackling.
Oh.
Uh, that one.
That looked like her up there, maybe?
Oh.
Oh, Big B, if you see any rations by the lava, don't do it.
It's a trap.
There's a whole lot of commotion going on in there.
Oh, I'm going.
Wee!
I'm still going.
Oh, wait, what was that?
Oh, holy cow!
Wait, I pressed D, though.
Oh, I'll just keep going, I guess.
There was something that I, like, pressed it, though.
Like, I was holding down, and I didn't get to click it.
Oh, come on!
How fast?
Am I supposed to time it?
Oh, shoot.
Ouch, that one actually got me.
Where are you?
Come out and face me.
Oh, I want to see her!
Whoa, freaky!
Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary!
Did you guys ever try Bloody Mary?
In the mirror?
Did I miss or did I not click it?
Can't tell.
Arrk!
She's so nimble.
Uh-oh.
Someone's gonna be falling into the lava.
I know.
Someone's gonna get Terminator'd for real.
Oh, I'm like, I've gone full wolf.
Release the wolf.
I'll never go full wolf, maybe.
Oh my gosh, it's so creepy.
The cracking of the mirror.
Oh, which one's real?
Oh, no, this is...
Naruto.
Sexy no Jutsu.
Okay.
Oh.
Ouch.
Oh, we're not gonna make it out of this.
This is so bad.
Why does she get all...
Why does she get to do this?
Ouch.
How does...
How is this a power of Bloody Mary?
I don't quite understand.
Unless the whole place is like made of mirrors.
It doesn't really...
It seems a little overpowered, I think.
Wait, wait, wait, we were not full wolf before.
Now we are full wolf.
Oh my god!
We've gotten fuller wolf!
We've gotten Twilight!
Oh damn, we just body slammed her.
Oh, maybe this will have like our glamour, you know?
This is...
I have no idea.
Is she the one that's controlling all of them?
Ouch!
What was that sound effect?
There's even more!
This seems too crazy, too overpowered.
Like, I know, like, Bloody Mary is kind of like, oh, she can
be anywhere, like, as long as you do the ritual or whatever,
but...
Oh, he's huffing and he's fluffing and he's blowing the
house down!
He huffed and he puffed!
Oh, dang.
No, she's gonna get us.
Oh!
Was that her, like, true form?
Her real...
Animorphs, back to normal.
Is he naked?
Surely the pants stayed on.
I don't think so.
Oh.
Oh, good.
He remembered to take them off before a...
you know oh hey there don't don't just stare gosh you want
me that bad or something
hello bigby you look tired give me one good reason not to
rip you apart right now yeah oh this gun holds six rounds of
specially designed silver bullets now i may not be the best
shot but i can guarantee that at least one bolt will meet
its mark and you'll find yourself rolling on the floor in
agony and able to heal yourself okay without swineheart to
save you you'll die is that reason enough for you before you
do anything okay yeah yeah i thought i should point out a
few let's let's see i want to hear him talk though i want
you to bring me back to the woodlands doesn't you and that's
what i want you're dealing with me now yeah you're dealing
with me now but maybe true But I'd advise against defying
your new boss At least for the time being you will bring me
back alive Look all I asked for is the chance to speak for
myself in front of the community.
What the I'm sure miss white would agree that I should be
given a fair trial I don't want to give him what he wants
agree on that.
I will have tell me now.
Wait, what?
The whole town will be calling for your execution.
Why would you want me to bring you back there?
about that huh look there's no reason for us to be at each
other's throats here that's funny coming from a guy pointing
a gun at my head yeah this is just a precaution I'm sure you
understand I'm no murderer mr.
wolf I didn't kill those women yeah you just got somebody
else to do it all I'm asking for is a chance to explain my
side yeah then what are you huh not a killer then what are
you what you huh what do you think i'm a businessman not a
killer there's still a lot you have to answer for and i will
as long as you agree to my terms because i'm not saying
another word until i'm brought before the community what and
i don't think i'm being unreasonable if you decide to do
something stupid like murder me you won't get your answers
but you will have a different time explaining yourself to
miss white and the rest of this miserable town why would
they care you're often reckless and i worry you're not
thinking of them let me ask you an honest question wait why
did he what do you really care about here where this case is
concerned i mean do you really want the truth or do you just
want to look like the hero ah it's about justice this is
about justice i'm the sheriff yeah i have to do what's right
yeah two people were murdered yeah and you know who did it
you under your orders
he's dead isn't he my point being the killer has been dealt
with we've won you really think i'm that stupid i understand
you have an obligation to bring me in but you can brighten
up a little it's over so shall we get going i'd rather not
dawdle ah you know i'm actually looking forward to seeing
miss white again my previous interactions with her have gone
rather well let's go i don't want to i think i'd rather hold
on to it oh no you are not in control what do you say okay
never mind hey i'm sure miss white will be pleased hey such
a reliable pup i understand why she'd want to keep you
around I'm listening to, I'm doing the proper things.
I don't want to spare him.
I don't.
And your punishment will follow.
I want to know what he says though.
Like I want to know why he wants to talk to everybody as
much as I want to like take care of him right now.
I want to know why he wants to be like in front of
everybody.
I know.
But we have to do something.
Are you fucking kidding me?
What is this thing happening?
Are we sure he's coming?
Yes, you'll have an opportunity to.
him he's back the crooked man motherfucker yeah spit on him
are you okay it's been hours we were worried you'd run into
some trouble uh at the crooked yeah he didn't make it easy
that's for sure he didn't make it easy what happened uh it
doesn't matter he's here we got him we can talk about it
later you did well sheriff i'm surprised what not that you
did well but okay you know i'm just glad you made it back in
one piece i want to put face in snow white you know this
asshole down the well yes what are you waiting for you
killed lily she was my sister could you have to say where
the do you get off you think you have the right to just do
this to people you're a fucking crook this you should be a
shit hole everyone can I have your attention thank you all
for coming here on such short notice I know normally is this
everybody in town I thought it best if we do this as soon as
possible is this all the are these all the fables left
charged with the murder as I already informed your sheriff
it was mr.
Georgie Porgie you killed those with George white georgie
may have killed them but you made the call do i have to
explain the situation to you again wait a minute so you're
saying georgie's the motherfucker who killed my sister well
where is it yeah you're gonna bring that head in too aren't
you yeah sheriff where is that rotten scouting wait how is
this going against me still out there i sincerely hope not
well where is he suffered paid for what he did in the end
there was a fight and he bled out from his wounds it's over
Is this turning against me?
So you see the culprit has been punished.
That doesn't change anything.
We'll deal with it later, but right now you're the one I'm
concerned with.
You called the shots.
Georgie made that perfectly clear.
In which case you still have a lot to answer for.
I was told I would be allowed to speak.
We have to read the rest of the charges.
What other charges?
If you'd wait a moment.
I'm well aware of my rights, Miss White.
Yeah, let her finish.
or finish and have your say yeah got it snow appreciated
that you are charged with the murder of faith and lily which
georgie carried out on your order inciting violence against
various members of the fabletown community including the
attempted murder of sheriff bigby wolf yes yes twice
understanding oh my god he's kind of great prostitution at
the pudding and pie additionally you are with multiple
counts of fraud, extortion, racketeering, and the illegal
possession and sale of magical artifacts.
And resisting arrest.
Oh, yes.
Now is there anything you would like to say?
First of all, I had nothing to do with Faith and Lily.
So you can strike...
Oh, he's just...
Oh, you're...
We're just taking his word at it.
That's so funny.
Stop the charade.
We know you're involved.
Nah, let him speak.
Let him speak.
Everyone just shut up.
I want to hear what he has to say.
He wanted a chance to talk.
We'll go ahead.
We all know he's guilty.
What the fuck does he need to speak for?
The crooked man has committed crimes against this government
and most importantly, its citizens.
These charges, if proven, are enough to justify death, upon
which your body will be committed to the witching well.
Where it fucking belongs.
The witch.
Oh, burn the witch.
Burn the witch.
Oh, wrong thing.
What do you really want to let him talk?
If we're ever going to pull ourselves together and make
something of this town, we have to start doing things
correctly.
No more snap judgments.
No more secrets.
We are going to treat everyone fairly.
I do think the snap judgments is, like, important, you know.
That's like a lot of people nowadays, too.
Things are very like...
A lot of things become black and white with people
sometimes.
And it's...
Not quite always that way.
Thank you, Miss White.
Wait!
have to tell you what kind of person why why did we free him
wait a second i'm so confused not that i'm saying the black
and white is like you know applicable here but kept to a
dying mother oh are you gonna get to your point or what
georgie was working for me yes but he was not acting on my
behalf when he killed those women it was his business and
for whatever reason i'm sure only he could understand he
murdered two of his most faithful employees i had nothing to
do with it.
This is such bullshit.
Yeah, he did cover it up.
If you were so offended by it, why'd you cover it up then?
If it had nothing to do with you and your shit, then why'd
you try to protect him for so long?
What cover up?
I never made any attempt to hide Georgie's criminal activity
from you.
I learned of it myself only recently.
Any of you actually believe this bullshit?
Holly, please.
Tell them, Bigby.
When you finally showed up at my door last night, wasn't I
more than helpful?
What do you mean?
to cooperate what's he talking um i was attacked and held at
gunpoint goons attacked me did you forget that part they get
a bit carried away sometimes it's true loyal to the end oh
he's the boss they want to protect me as i protected them
yeah protected them from murder this is so great you might
even give up an innocent man just to save someone they
didn't want what's he Wait, wait.
Yeah, right.
They don't do it because they want to protect you.
I wasn't paying attention, sorry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You scare tactics.
They're afraid if they don't follow orders, they'll end up
dead.
Yeah, that's true too, though.
Let me explain this to you.
My employees are just that.
Hired help.
I see some of them are here among you.
They are not my slaves.
They are all free to make their own decisions, as Georgie
was.
What about Lily?
She wasn't free.
She wasn't given a choice.
Do you really think she wanted...
that any of those girls wanted their lives like that?
I'm sorry, Holly.
I'm sorry that your sister asked me for help, and I'm sorry
that I decided against my better judgment to give her a
distasteful job.
Right, and you kept them in debt so they couldn't leave.
Yeah!
That's what you did to us, how you kept us all in line.
You forget it was not me who put you in that position.
You all act like I'm some kind of tyrant.
When your government abandoned you, They're just poor and
helpless, sniveling on street corners.
I was there to look out for you.
This is so messed up.
Yes, but wasn't I?
That was Craig.
Dane was the one who let this town go to the fucking dogs.
The guy who was in your pocket, remember?
Really?
What about Archie Greenleaf?
Her story is not uncommon.
She left everything she had back in the homelands.
Everything that matters anyway.
With nowhere else to turn, she came to me.
for help and what did I do for you you got my tree back I
got her tree back and in turn we used her magic to help poor
fables get glamours because I helped her she was able to
make a living provide for herself this is so crazy not much
but they asked me to come work for them really the new
deputy mayor want you on the 13th floor no the wolf offered
me the job she wanted my tree destroyed if she had had her
way I'd be hung out to dry on a clothesline by now what oh
you were gonna burn her tree snow don't try to manipulate I
know what you're doing it's not gonna work you can't
manipulate us or these people we're not here to talk oh
we're not I think we just mean this is important and I'm
glad it's being talked about you know why I asked him to
destroy your tree you were working with Crane and the
crooked man it wasn't her fault you can lie to yourself but
you can't lie to me you hated Crane and you hated him for
wanting to fuck you and you being too soft to notice what
he'd do to get it it had nothing to do with a crooked man
we've made some mistakes I've made some mistakes but believe
me i truly want what's best for this town and that may not
always be clear right away but i want you all to know that i
care deeply about all of you and so does the sheriff yeah
right i can't promise you perfection no one can but i can
promise to always have your best interests we'll do better
we'll do better haven't been great for a while now but we'll
do better at protecting you from people like what about the
where's mr.
toad and where's Colin we stopped them from going to the
farm exploiting your hope for a better life you would go to
him for help and he would take that weakness and add it to
his strength and if things didn't fall exactly his way
someone would die he took faith in Lily from us yeah let's
appeal that and while we can never get them back we can
certainly punish who's responsible yeah they're right the
beast you're all still afraid of him even now but you
needn't be his contamination of this town is over those
girls will have their justice I know he like shackled people
to make magic for him very good very good the sentiment is
surely appreciated miss white but it doesn't disguise the
fact that these accusations are completely unfounded oh my
god this is crazy the sheriff simply doesn't have a particle
of evidence linking me to the georgie was working for you
bigby got a confession confession that nobody heard now yeah
that's true but i think such a statement would carry more
weight if bigby weren't the only one to whom georgie spoke
especially given bigby's history what are you talking about
wait what snow So what about wait?
What about your history all you've done to this fucking
town?
What do you mean?
There's no evidence.
Oh, that's also not true Maybe he's I mean this doesn't feel
right how we're doing this.
Wait, what?
I just of course it's right.
This man tormented all of you for profit.
Yeah, let me just make sure I understand you You're trying
to say that I'm responsible for what Georgie did because he
was working for me at the time.
Yes, yes Of course.
Where are you going with this?
Is he going to say...
Yeah!
That was self-defense.
He killed a man.
That was justified.
For fuck's sake, killing someone who's trying to kill you is
hardly...
They were there to retrieve crane.
You didn't need to escalate things.
They pointed the gun!
Who sent those two freaks anyway?
Bigby and I have already discussed his behavior that night.
We're handling it internally.
How about the way he treated poor Tweedle Dee when he was in
your custody?
I didn't do anything!
He was beaten to mashed apples while under your watch.
Under my watch.
That was also Crane.
Maybe he's right.
Did you think we'd all just let that go?
Snow wasn't involved.
Snow had nothing to do with it.
We all thought she was dead.
Besides, Crane was still deputy mayor when that happened.
Yes, he was.
Right before you decided to kidnap him.
It was for his own protection.
Oh, you're right, dear.
crane was in charge sometimes it's hard to tell the
difference huh that's enough so you won't answer for your
employees behavior but I must perish for this is completely
different I did not order those two girls dead it simply
never happened Georgie killed Faith and Lily end of story
they were like we're like slipping but they refused to
answer for their own crisis right oh please this isn't the
point we'll deal with them after we deal with you listen i
know laws apply when we need them okay i need everybody to
stop talking talk down this isn't the reason we're here
privilege should be afforded to this is how it's always been
this is what i'm talking about we lashed our ropes to this
disease world and ever since which one of us has been there
for you who filled your life with the promise of more who
was there while they idly played in that well everybody
wanted this guy dead like beauty and beast we're just like
we hate this guy take care of him and now they're like me
who will pay your rent when you're in the virgin eviction
now they're all like siding with him oh my gosh challenge
their brutality when it leaks to our dear citizens who will
protect you from the big bad wolf no who will be the big b
miss white oh finally thank you wait somebody that can
actually...
I...
I wanted to make sure I had the chance to say something.
Why don't you take a moment to catch your breath?
What's she doing here?
What?
She has every right to be here.
I'd like to...
I need to say something.
We're kind of in the middle of something.
She has something to say.
Yeah.
She has something to say, and we're gonna listen.
Go right ahead.
Yeah.
You probably don't remember me.
I don't know why I was afraid to come here.
Just shut up.
Ooh, you...
enslaved us for years let us hear stories about what you do
told us we would lose everything if we stepped just one toe
out of line we couldn't say a word about it because of these
damn ribbons oh but you know what now it's my turn to talk
how are you I found Vivian's body did you kill her did he
sure this is highly irregular he might as well have he might
as well have I'm sorry um I don't think Narissa my name is
Narissa yeah Narissa he ordered them dead this fucker faith
and Lily that's a lie I was in the goddamn room when he did
it faith and Lily are dead because of you the only two
people who ever gave a damn about me and now I can finally
say yeah and he's gonna pay for it he's gonna Yeah, he's
gonna pay for it.
He made George.
You are winning the crowd!
Georgie would have never done anything without his say-so,
ever.
You're going to take the word of a stupid...
At least five other girls will back me up on this.
We all heard you say it.
But there's five other people?
Where are they?
Did you know?
Looks like we found our evidence.
She saw it firsthand.
He's guilty.
Guilty!
Burn the witch!
So that's it, right?
Calm down the witching well!
Witching well!
I want to see you in the well like that.
What do you mean?
He's got to pay for what he did.
Listen to yourselves You're all rats fleeing from one
sinking ship to the next.
Yeah, he thinks she's so much better than us Miserable lives
afloat.
This is how you want to repay all I've done for you What you
take two people's lives away and now you want mercy, you
know We can't let you go free after this.
Yeah, what did you expect?
What did you expect to happen here?
well done then check now may your sentence we don't have to
become murder what are you talking about he's guilty i know
that but we don't have to kill anybody we can imprison him
lock him up forever oh genie genie him how can we be sure he
won't escape i can help we'll use magic that's not good
enough maybe she has more if he isn't stopped i don't get so
we get rid of him That's fun.
Clearly, we're having trouble agreeing on a suitable
punishment.
So I think we- Oh my gosh, stop interrupting!
Who?
I hope you aren't suggesting yourself.
Why not?
What about a vote?
What do you think this is?
Everyone calm down.
We can vote.
We can have a vote.
Make a democratic.
What's a vote?
Do you really think that's going to work?
Why not?
Nobody can agree on anything.
What about Big B?
What about him?
He was appointed.
He's the only official.
official representative really he should be the judge oh v
that makes sense to me that makes sense to me fine are you
sure this isn't how it's what the people want miss white
okay okay yeah wolf it's your call oh my god that's so
exciting do what you think is right lock him up and throw
away the key rip his head off that's kind of insane we don't
want to do it so bad no he has to Just fucking get rid of
him.
Not this way.
That was too slow.
He's gonna take me down the well.
Let's go.
It was so close to ripping off his head.
Okay, bye.
There you are.
I hope you remember this moment.
Think of me when you try to sleep.
Nah, I'm gonna lock him up.
Oh, after he did that, then, I'm gonna lock him up.
You said you had a way to keep him from hurting people.
Wait, you can't be serious.
You're just gonna put him in prison?
This isn't the way.
Turn him into a rat.
Yes, there's a way.
Let him become a...
A worm.
Oh, the choice is...
The choice is blank.
Wait.
What's happening?
Someone's gonna see you, Colin.
Wait, what just happened?
Did my game bug?
Why is it so quiet?
Are you gonna come see the truck off?
We're leaving for the farm in a few.
Thought you might want to.
I don't know.
I'll be down in a minute.
Wait, what's going on?
The choice is blank!
Guys?
I think my game bugged.
I should have ripped off his head
Wait, can I move?
If I resume the game, what happens?
Oh my god The choice is blank!
The choice is blank!
This is great.
This is so funny.
Let's go back to the main menu And see Surely it saved After
I made the decision, right?
Okay.
Continue.
One day later.
Oh, this is already a little different.
Wait, but what happened?
Oh, let's just...
Oh, wait, he's a crow.
Narissa!
Ravencroft!
Morning, crooked man.
He's got a sharp tongue.
I thought it would be better for everyone if he parted with
it.
work is work I guess hey sheriff are you gonna come see the
truck off we're leaving for the farm in a few thought you
might want to I don't know I'll be down in a minute wait
where did Colin come wait where did Colin go she also has a
ribbon are the ribbons just like their uniforms now or
something Oh, hello.
Oh.
Uh, Mr. Wolf?
Flycatcher left his keys.
Where did Colin go?
Uh, everything okay?
Is everything okay?
You look...
I'm...
I'm sorry, Sheriff.
I have to take care of this.
I think you need an assistant.
We'll talk later, okay?
How could everybody in the whole town have problems?
Good morning, Miss White.
You're late.
Oh, she does have an assistant.
It's him.
Does she not like us anymore?
Oh, there he is.
Someone's gonna see you, Colin.
There he is.
What happened before?
Wait, what happened after?
Look at him go.
Just wobble.
Hobbling away.
Okay.
Who lives in the penthouse, I wonder?
This is so awkward.
Why is there no music?
Web and Muffet Market.
That's funny.
Yeah, where is Little Miss Tuffet?
Oh, you're not going to the farm, are you?
Wait, but the glamour!
Oh, darling, Jesus.
We only have like five minutes.
They carry me for facts sake.
I don't give a shit.
Mr. Todd!
Thank you.
It's been pretty busy around here.
Nice fucking day.
Don't be so dramatic.
I tried to help.
Yeah, don't be so dramatic.
It's just a farm.
You don't have to be so dramatic about it.
Just why the hell did she have to send me and me boy away,
huh?
You promised me I'll get another chance.
But Miss White said I had to go up to the damn farm anyway.
Oh, you...
I told her I had the money, but she didn't want to hear it.
into the glamour sheriff bigby i have something how is that
tj you know he was up crying all night okay can you give
this to miss white please dad says there's no time to say
goodbye no if you could bring it i'm busy we could be the
worst sure sure what is it i can't be mean to tj he's too
cute she said she liked that one the best oh that's a little
beetle that's a big one they're cool because when they're
little they have these pouches that squirt juice at you if
you touch them she'll love it sure she'll love it she said
it was pretty we're about ready to remember that what's it
like at the farm i've heard ogres live there and they eat
people in their sleep sometimes god i hope not do we have to
go i want to stay We don't have a choice anymore.
Your dad broke the rules.
TJ will remember that.
Follow the rules.
Oh, it's so sad.
Have you been there before?
Oh.
Some of the animals aren't comfortable around wolves.
So you wouldn't know, would you?
It's raining.
It's pouring.
Bye, Mr. Wolf.
Oh, TJ.
What?
Where's your friend, Colin?
Where's a fucking pig?
Must be missing.
I don't know.
He must have run off.
Oh, shit.
Mr. Toad, you're going to hell.
Saying goodbye.
Oh.
Where are you going?
you think she likes me hi hi you're still wearing that then
oh yeah I guess I am it's not easy to forget I know it seems
like I should be able can I do it it's just let me help big
B I I know you're trying to help this is just something I
Okay, let me get in there a little bit.
I can't know because I have to tell you something.
What?
What is it?
It's about what happened to Faith and Lily.
I'm not sure where to start.
What's that?
Faith, Lily and I, we had this plan.
We were going to find a way out.
Leave the pudding and pie for good.
But then Faith decided to get some leverage.
She stole a picture of Crane and Lily together.
That's why she's had the picture.
faith stole that photo we had dirt on one of the crooked
man's allies if he found out i i had no choice you have to
understand you've seen how they kept us quiet in that place
can you imagine the lengths they go just to silence someone
who had physical yeah what did you what marissa just tell me
what happened i freaked out okay i thought if i came clean
to georgie he'd get the crooked man
Try again in a few years.
You ratted them out!
Told him everything.
And I begged for mercy for all of us.
I didn't want anyone to die over a picture.
Oh, you sold out your friends?
So you sold them out?
No.
Yes.
Yeah.
Georgie promised he'd smooth things over with the crooked
man.
Oh.
But then...
Oh, God.
Give her a cigarette.
Tell me more.
What happened?
Can you tell me anything else?
I think we know the full story, but you know.
I don't know what happened.
But that night at the club, Georgie came back and told me
things had changed.
Why'd they leave the heads on the step is what I want at
all?
We had committed treason.
We would have never looked into it, you know?
We're sitting there as he was telling me this.
Faith walked in and I had to watch while Georgie...
this not the crooked man back at the well you know what I
said but it wasn't the truth was it what does it matter I
know the crooked man did it so what if it wasn't the whole
truth it was true enough oh oh shouldn't have lied that
makes it okay to lie I know he ordered their deaths I wasn't
gonna let him get away with it because of a stupid
technicality especially a car driving in the back that night
after faith yeah i tried to warn lily but she wasn't with
her scheduled appointment so i did the only thing i could do
i i left faith's head that's a wow my question was answered
you i walked her over here
maybe if i couldn't save so how i know this you were trying
to get my attention yeah yeah so you you started all this
whoa i just pointed you in the right direction people like
us get forgotten all the time the crooked man was counting
on that oh when we suffer we do it in silence and the world
likes it that way we just fade like we never existed i
couldn't watch that happen to faith or a lily nobody cares
about us that won't happen anymore i promise yeah things
like that won't happen anymore not while i'm around yeah
make things right you and snow i don't know seems like no
matter what i do it's just not enough for her or anyone i
just can't win with these people i know it might feel that
way but they need you big b both of you you two make a good
team the way you look out for each other and look out for us
you don't see that a lot these days I don't know where we
stand where we stand anymore yeah things are just different
huh things are always different look big B after everything
you've done for us maybe they don't want to admit it but
without you none of this would have happened true when no
one else would you protected your friends no matter the cost
and you brought justice to this town yeah yeah everyone saw
who he really was so from where i'm standing you did the
right thing you've been given this job for a reason and i
left faith at your doorstep because i knew if anyone stood a
chance against the crooked man i mean i did make a lot of
mistakes I've been making a lot of mistakes lately.
But you've also done a lot of good.
Don't forget that.
You've changed this place.
For better or worse.
Oh, we have somebody on our side!
Fable Time.
We're the big, good wolf.
You're not as bad as a prince as you are.
Oh!
I need to tell you.
I have to tell you something.
I feel like we've met before.
I'm trying to replace me.
Do you like my ribbon?
Do you like it?
Faith wore one too.
What hide her beauty so she could escape his kingdom?
They used to call me the little mermaid.
Did Dr. Swinehart ever get back to you about Faith?
He said he wanted to run more tests.
I hope you find what you're looking for.
Wait, what?
Go after her?
We could...
I'll see you around.
Wolf.
You and 31% of players left Georgie to die.
You and 89% of players brought the crooked man back alive.
Wow.
How did you punish the crooked man?
You and 47% of players chose to imprison him.
Dang.
98% of people accepted.
Accepted TJ's gift.
That's great.
You and 29% of players said I've made a lot of mistakes.
My last words to Narissa.
But I went after her.
We went after her.
Yay!
Sometimes in these games, it's like so tough to want to
like, do something that I would do versus just trying to
like stir stuff up a little bit in the game you know what i
mean you told him that you saw beauty outside the apartment
you impressed her with your detective skills i did you
fought him after the interrogation i did you gave him a
drink when he asked for one in your apartment and you helped
him avoid the farm colin colin didn't do anything you took
him back to the witching well you imprisoned him you
confiscated these money while he was in custody you killed
you left him to die you smashed up his place you took his
money i sound like the worst you left him to die and you
smashed up his place and you took his money you drank with
gran after lily's funeral you kicked on her door you offered
her a job you tried to take her ribbon during your final
conversation you paid her extra money
date you brought her along with you to the trip trap you
promised to bring the crooked man back alive you chose to
wait for him tiny tim you accepted his beetle and promised
to give it to snow you mr toad is the last guy you stood up
for him when snow wanted to send him to the farm and you
gave him money i think i treated him the best mr toad I
gotta get you to hell, man.
Wow, what a fun game.
I really want to go back and be the big bad wolf.
I can't believe I was like, you're the big nice wolf.
And then she says, you're not as bad as everyone says you
are.
We basically said the same exact thing.
Come on, put me in the writer's room.
You'll get such sick lines as, you're the big nice wolf.
I
What's funny about these games, too, is you'll make a choice
thinking it kind of means something else, and then it means
something else entirely, and you're like, whoa, whoa, wait a
second, that's not what I was thinking.
But wow, I, you know, it was so, I really liked the Crooked
Man.
I like characters that are
how do you say they are evil but they're like smooth talkers
but also they kind of fall in this like gray area where like
with him he's just like yeah I was helping I helped you get
your tree back and I helped employ you and I helped you keep
your lights on and keep your apartment things like that but
I mean underneath it all like he was imprisoning them the
beast and beauty were the They were the worst.
The fact that they were so like, we hate Big B, but also Big
B help us, but also we hate the crooked man, but also he
might be okay.
Like so wishy-washy the entire time.
Getting everybody else in their own drama.
Oh my goodness.
I'm kind of lukewarm on snow.
I feel like I don't really don't like the ending that with
her not that I wanted us to like you know get together
romantically or anything.
Oh cool.
There's graphic novels but like It feels like nothing
changed in a sense Like we Clearly like we did so much We
you know helped so much we didn't kill him kill the crooked
man or anything and yet in the end she was just kind of like
oh oh you know sorry big B I can't even a bit of it not
right now like she didn't even treat us like you know we
were on the same team like kind of with that we were on the
same level I don't know I don't know how I feel about that I
didn't like that very much but other than that um it really
sucks that my game bugged out and i didn't get to really see
what i mean we saw that he got turned into a crow
um that was really silly me um minto the uh quality
assurance player but i hope you guys liked it too i would
probably want to go back through this game and be just a
total asshole to everybody even tj unfortunately like it's
so it's so tough sometimes to be like yeah this is how i
feel versus this is how i would get another story or like a
different kind of outcome than what i would usually get you
know what i mean so if i made choices that made you be like
scratching your head or being like what the heck i mean
though it's mostly just that sometimes it's just fun to be a
little to cause a little chaos.
To be a little shit sometimes.
But yay!
The Wolf Among Eyes.
I really liked it.
I liked the setting.
I think the aesthetic of it was really good.
Like this menu is so cool.
Oh, let's see the extras real quick.
Book of Fables.
Oh, let's see.
Sheriff Bigby.
After fleeing the homeland's Bigby, many years wandering
through europe with a fable colony quickly developing in the
new world snow white and feather top tracked down the wolf
and offered him passage to fable to feather top he agreed
and snow cut him with a lycanthropy stained knife to give
him the power to change into a human form at will oh big b
became sheriff of fable town under king cole's
administration but because of his violent past many fables
didn't trust him and he was banned from ever foot on the
farm to this day he struggles to redeem himself in the eyes
of the community a new order with crane out of the picture
mayor cole has been officially appointed snow white as the
director of operations and deputy mayor in his absence many
would say this promotion is a long time coming since she was
instrumental in the establishment of fable town and
personally ensured that many fables made it to the new world
safely she's been doing the work of deputy Mary unofficially
for years.
Oh, Mary's loyalty.
She was crazy.
Bloody Mary began working for the Crookin' Man many
centuries ago.
He promised her freedom to do as she pleased as long as she
agreed to act as his personal bodyguard and hitman.
I'm not a murderer.
I just send people to murder.
Because of the Crookin' Man's power and influence, Mary
never had to worry about getting caught by the authorities.
dang she enjoys her job immensely and would defend the
crooked man to the death mostly because she finds it fun
crazy of crooked man crime lord the crooked man has slowly
built himself into one of the most powerful figures in fable
town his operation started with a crooked sixpence and a
crooked house two things he cared about more than his wife
or children whom he killed rather than let's stand in his
way.
Oh my god!
They don't tell you any of this stuff.
Everybody's just like, oh, he's fine.
He makes a lot of sense.
In his rise, the crooked man has ensnared many fables in his
criminal web, providing them with what they need, but always
at a high cost.
He is cunning, persuasive, and ruthless.
Oh, I love villains like that.
They're so fun.
Where you're just like, oh, wait, maybe he makes a good
point.
Maybe he's not so bad, and you're just like, Oh, wait a
second.
Vivian.
The first to bear the curse of the purple rib.
I can't believe it was the girl with the ribbon this whole
time!
Cool.
We still missed one thing in five.
I guess, like, uh...
Maybe if we had killed Georgie.
Hmm.
It's so funny that I'm getting bugged.
But, uh...
Cool, cool.
Thank you guys so much for...
Enjoying...
I hope you enjoyed.
The Wolf of Munguice!
I love...
I was really in the mood for, like, a story-heavy game.
And sometimes it's hard to, like, talk in these games,
though, because they are doing all the talking.
And I'm just...
I'm just...
I'm, like, a fly on the wall.
I just feel like I'm interrupting.
But I had so much fun with this one.
I hope you guys had fun.
And yeah, I would like to play more Telltale games.
Not the Walking Dead.
But I'd like to do the Minecraft one.
Or there's a what?
There's a Back to the Future one?
Hopefully in the future.
Yippee!
Thank you guys so, so much.
Thank you, thank you.
And I will see you when I see you next.
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time zone.
Utsumi-to!
I'll see you when I haunt you next!
Bye bye!
Thank you!